toute la journée ils ont déposé des
fleurs ils ont prié 14 chandelle pour
quatorze marins qui sont morts dans des
conditions atroces asphyxiés dans les
profondeurs de la mer de baraki page a
agi de façon héroïque pour contenir les
flammes a déclaré le ministre de la
défense avant d'observer à son tour une
minute de silence une minute pour ces
hommes parmi lesquels figuraient sept
capitaines de classe et de héros russe
la plus haute distinction au pays tombe
sur une perte tragique pour la marine a
dit vladimir poutine qui a convoqué son
ministre d'urgence et ordonné une
enquête sur le championnat n'était pas
investi ordinaire mais un engin de
rechercher tous à bord étaient des plus
professionnels a ajouté le président qui
s'est bien gardé d'en dire plus sur le
type de submersion rome et pour cause
selon plusieurs quotidiens russes
il s'agirait du lot charic cette photo
est la seule qui existe de ce sous-marin
ultrasecret conçu à l'époque de l'union
soviétique pour mener des missions
militaires spéciales à plus de 2000
mètres sous l'eau soit une profondeur
deux fois plus grande que pour un sous
marin normal il est évident qu'il
s'agissait d'un simple et c'est tout
près de la base dit l'analyste militaire
pavel pergl puisque les hauts gradés de
la marine était à bord mais il a du mal
à s'expliquer pourquoi la russie
investit encore dans ce type de
submersibles et cet accident n'est pas
sans rappeler aux russes la tragédie du
sous marin koursk qui avait coûté la vie
à 118 marins
en l'an 2000 et mis en lumière le piètre
état d'équipements militaires russes
malgré les sommes investies depuis pour
moderniser l'équipement militaire
les tragédies en russie sont encore
fréquentes en mer ou dans les airs le
ministre de la défense a confirmé que
plusieurs marins ont survécu à
l'incendié mais il ne dit pas combien ni
où ils sont ce soir
d'ailleurs le kremlin prévient que
toutes les informations relatives à
l'accident seront classées secret d'état
tout comme le sont les opérations
militaires menées par la russie dans sa
conquête du grand nord ici tu amaral des
restos radio-canada moscou